well friends today we are scraping the
bottom of the cauldron for this one
freaky folks here lies a group of
wretched movies with the lowest tomato
meters of all time with a minimum of 20
reviews now rising and shambling into
our guide of the worst reviewed horror
movies ever made
[Music]
now no movie listed here achieved higher
than nine percent on the tomato meter as
you might expect the list features
remakes sequels that no one asked for
and then there are movies so bad that
they will never even get a sniff of a
chance for a sequel so brace yourself as
we count down the worst reviewed horror
movies of all time
[Music]
starting with number 10
when four bodies are discovered among
the industrial decay and urban grime of
new york city young detective mike riley
teams with ambitious department of
health researcher terry huston to
uncover the cause behind their violent
and inexplicable deaths the only common
factor shared by the victims each died
exactly 48 hours after logging on to
fear.com starring stephen dorf natasha
mcallone steven raya and directed by
william malone critics say as
frustrating as a 404 error fear.com is a
stylish incoherent and often nasty mess
with few scares
come and find out
don't you want to play with me
do you want to hurt me
you're lying
how enticing the smell of cheap perfume
can be
number nine bless the child
when maggie's sister jenna saddles her
with an autistic newborn named cody she
touches maggie's heart and becomes the
daughter she's always longed for but six
years later jenna suddenly re-enters her
life and with her mysterious new husband
eric stark abducts cody despite the fact
that maggie has no legal rights to cody
fbi agent john travis takes up her cause
when he realizes that cody shares the
same birth date as several other
recently missing children starring kim
bae singer jimmy smits holliston coleman
and directed by chuck russell critics
say bless the child squanders its
talented cast on a plot that's more
likely to inspire unintentional laughs
than shivers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after you
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
number eight the hunting of molly
hartley
after surviving a brutal attack by her
insane mother teenage molly is eager to
get a fresh start at a new school
attracting the attention of one of the
school's most popular students she
thinks she is finally fitting in and
getting her life on track but on the eve
of her 18th birthday molly learns the
horrifying truth about her devilish
legacy starring hayley bennett chase
crawford annalynne mccord and directed
by mickey little critics say the
haunting of molly hartley is a rather
lifeless horror endeavor with a
pedestrian plot and few scares
that's so beautiful thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's wrong
you're hearing things again
no no i don't know i should know it's
just a headache
i'm fine
i'm fine
i just want to get out of here okay
dad
get in the car
[Music]
[Music]
put some clothes on
[Music]
number seven alone in the dark
when the investigations of supernatural
detective edward carnby lead him to
uncover a long-lost tribe called the
absconi he finds out that they worship
demons these evil creatures are now
attempting to resurface in the world and
edward can stop them only with the help
of a lean sedrack an archaeologist who
also happens to be his old flame with
sinister forces attempting to take over
edward's mind can he and elene stop them
before it's too late starring christian
slater tara reed steven dorf and
directed by ouvey bowl critics say inept
on almost every level alone in the dark
may not work as a thriller but it's good
for some head slapping incredulous
laughter
uh
uh
aah
[Music]
number six return of the living dead
part two
a boy and his friends free something
evil from a canister fallen off an army
truck starring michael kenworthy tom
matthews james caron and directed by ken
wiederhorn critics say zero brains
oh jesus
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my god
oh oh oh oh
oh oh
oh oh
[Music]
oh
god oh get rid of it please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
get that damn screwdriver out of my head
[Music]
number five homecoming
a jealous woman plots revenge after her
former beau returns to their hometown
with a pretty new girlfriend starring
misha barton jessica strope matt long
and directed by morgan j freeman critics
say a lazy collection of obsession
thriller cliches homecoming will leave
viewers wishing they'd opted for a
lopsided football game and some awkward
dancing instead if that selfish just
died one month earlier i could have gone
with you
i could have gone with you to school and
everything would be all right
things would still be the way they were
she was your mom shelby i can't believe
you just said that what the hell is
wrong with you
please mikey
you're all i got
please don't put me in this position
hey
come on it's gonna be okay
just give it a little time
number four the disappointments room
dana her husband david and their
five-year-old son lucas start a new life
after moving from the hustle and bustle
of brooklyn new york to a stately old
manor in the quiet countryside after
settling in dana starts to experience
terrifying visions and dreams that she
can't explain the mystery grows when she
stumbles upon a secret room in the attic
after finding the key and unlocking the
door dana discovers the dark history of
the family that lived there in the 19th
century starring kate beckinsale mel
rydo gerald mcraney and directed by dj
caruso critics say the disappointments
room lives down to its title with a
thrill-free thriller that presumably
left its stars filled with regret and
threatens to do the same for audiences
lucas is that you
lucas
please
[Music]
number three cabin fever fresh out of
college five friends face the horrors of
a flesh-eating virus while staying at a
remote cabin starring gage go lightly
matthew d'addario nadine crocker and
directed by travis zaroony critics say
no need for a quarantine enthusiasm for
this inert remake is not contagious
help me
[Music]
i need a doctor uh get down with
blankets
he's thinking he needs help okay
what no
look at him
i mean he's got something he's got
something bad oh we need to call him a
doctor call someone okay no no no we
don't have any receptions
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that freak is going to the car
what
what
hey
hey get the [ __ ] out
oh
[Music]
number two jaws the revenge
the family of widow ellen brody has long
been plagued by shark attacks and this
unfortunate association continues when
her son is a victim of a massive great
white in mourning ellen goes to visit
her other son michael in the bahamas
where she meets the charming hoagie
nukem as ellen and hoagie begin a
relationship a huge shark appears off
the coast of the island and ellen's
troubles with the great whites begins
again starring lorraine gary michael
kane lance guess and directed by joseph
sargent critics say illogical
tension-free and filled with cut-rate
special effects jaws 4 the revenge is a
sorry chapter in a once proud franchise
such a live wire level to make your hair
stick up funny that's good michael
william yeah there's no hope for that
boy
jake that's a joke
we got a big fish down here man
oh yeah how big
[Music]
what's wrong
ellen
[Music]
no you're not i'm terrific
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
the apparition
plagued by frightening occurrences in
their home kelly and ben learned that a
university's parapsychology experiment
produce an entity that is now haunting
them the malevolent spirit feeds on fear
and torments the couple no matter where
they run desperate kelly and ben turn to
a paranormal researcher but even with
his aid it may already be too late to
save themselves from the terrifying
presence starring ashley greene
sebastian stan tom felton and directed
by todd lincoln critics say the
apparition fails to offer anything
original isn't particularly scary and
offers so little in the way of dramatic
momentum that it's more likely to put
you to sleep than thrill you
so
[Applause]
uh
ah
[Music]
house of the dead
simon and greg meet a group of friends
and set out to attend a rave on a remote
island when they miss the ferry they
decide to ride with kirk a smuggler they
find the island deserted and discovered
that the party-goers have been killed by
zombies now the group must evade the
deadly creatures and try to find safety
however the only means of escape kirk's
boat has been overrun forcing the
survivors to ward off the undead
starring jonathan cherry tyron lytzo
clint howard and directed by ouvey bol
critics say a grungy disjointed mostly
brainless mess of a film house of the
dead is nonetheless loaded with
unintentional laughs
[Music]
[Music]
the darkness
peter taylor his wife ronnie and their
two children returned to los angeles
after a fun-filled vacation to the grand
canyon strange events soon start to
plague the family including young son
michael's increasingly erratic behavior
the tailors learned that michael brought
back some mysterious rocks that he
discovered inside a cave and
unfortunately something followed them
home as the clan now find themselves in
a battle with a supernatural force that
preys on their worst fears starring
kevin bacon roddon mitchell david mizus
and directed by greg mclean critics say
the darkness clumsily relies on an
assortment of genre tropes leaving only
the decidedly non-frightening ghosts of
superior horror films in its wake
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
what the hell is that
and finally the number one worst horror
movie is one miss call
when beth raymond witnesses the deaths
of two friends she knows there's more at
work than just a tragic coincidence days
before they die both victims hear their
terrifying final moments on cell phones
now although the police think beth is
crazy detective jack andrews believes
her together the pair try to unravel the
mystery behind the horrifying messages
before their own phone numbers come up
starring shannon sosman edward burns
anna claudia talancon and directed by
eric valet critics say one of the
weakest entries in the j horror remake
sweepstakes one missed call is undone by
bland performances and shop worn shocks
every time i turn around
oh
ah
[Music]
moment
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and for
even more news scores and
recommendations on the latest tv shows
and movies head on over to
rhinetomatos.com until next time i'm
your host naz perez and we'll see you
back here for more top 10s on the rotten
tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you